bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture d'un téléphone bonjour
trice carmouze bonjour on va parler de
fab de l'histoire des femmes à travers
trois romans absolument formidable
d'alain leblanc bonjour alain leblanc
bonjour alors trois tomes dont qui nous
conduisent de 1890 à 2000 à travers donc
trois romans les chaînes ça se passe
entre 1890 et 1930 la résistance qui
nous conduit de 1930 à 1960 et un
souffle d'indépendance de 1960 aux
années 2000 les héroïnes sur des des
femmes
trois romans dont qui porte à la fois
sur l'inégalité hommes femmes mais aussi
sur le combat de ces femmes pour gagner
leur indépendance et leur liberté
nathalie peut-être un mot sur un jeu
blanc avant de l'interroger oui vous
sera le blanc bonjour alain leblanc
bonjour alors vous avez été journaliste
scénariste également pour le cinéma et
la télévision romancier bien sûr vous
avez obtenu le prix de la vocation dès
votre premier roman une fille pour
l'hiver et vous est aussi l'auteur d'un
pont entre deux rives un magnifique
livre qui a été adapté au cinéma et
coréalisé c'est
exactement tard gérard depardieu alors
alain leblanc comment est née cette saga
sur la libération des femmes qui est un
thème quand même généralement qu'on
retrouve plus dans les essais que dans
les romans
mais écoutez souvent le sujet de roman
se trouve dans la vie moi j'ai été
élevée par une femme d'un seul
mères-célibataires dans les années 50 et
récemment divorcée et j'ai toujours vu
se battre contre la société des hommes
enfants n'avaient aucun droit
aucune aide elle était en butte vraiment
pouvoir masculin et puis à partir de là
je me suis interrogée à savoir comment
commencer à passer pour les normes pour
ma grand mère mon arrière grand mère et
a finalement je me suis aperçu que les
grands combats des femmes pour leur
liberté
finalement a démarré avec le 20e siècle
la fin du 19e siècle avec les
suffragettes au royaume uni et puis la
seconde guerre mondiale les femmes ont
occupé des postes
si cela occupés par des hommes et ont
montré qu'elles étaient en tant
qu'individu légal
par cette bande des hommes parce
qu'elles ont fait marcher le pays quand
les armes étaient au front 14 jusqu'à 18
et je me suis dit que finalement c'était
intéressant de montrer le combat sur
tout le xxème siècle et sur des
générations successives parce que ce ces
pubs se sont transmises évidemment
jusque jusqu'aux années 2000
c'est vrai moi ce sont des générations
de de deux femmes on va commencer par le
le premier qui nous conduit donc de 1890
à 1930 c'est roman s'appelle les chaînes
et ça dit bien ce que ça veut dire
l'héroïne cc clémence son père l'homme
est prise parce que elle a un frère est
alors le frère c'est très bien c'est un
homme elle ils sont enfin une l'homme et
président là il ne la regarde pas ne la
calcule pas quand vous dirait des années
aujourd'hui les femmes c'est fait pour
obéir pour être là il la marie de force
d'ailleurs avec avec un homme qu'elle
n'aime pas
se marient peu lui importe que sa femme
ne l'aiment pas il est là pour commander
pour faire ses affaires c'est vraiment
quand on lit parce que le roman est
formidablement bien fait et parce qu'on
essaie haletant quoi on essaye de savoir
comment elle va se sortir de ses chaînes
là
on a l'impression quand même lui que la
femme
elle est soumise totalement à la volonté
de l'homme cette époque là complètement
on commet dans cette aile son statut
d'ailleurs les mère élevait leurs filles
par rapport à ça c'est à dire bon de
monde tu vas te marier qu'il choisira
pas forcément tomari mais tu auras tes
enfants tu seras au foyer tu là pour les
élever et rien d'autre tu seras sous la
tutelle de ton mari comme tu es sous la
tutelle de ton père et c'était le statut
de la femme de cette époque que ça a été
on peut remonter d'ailleurs très très
loin dans l'histoire
de l'art de toppi dans les sociétés
occidentales
c'était comme ça et ça a été comme ça
sur tous tous deux un tracteur de
vraiment puis jusqu'à jusqu'à fermement
au fond
jusqu'à la second moitié disons du 20e
siècle
jens est d'ailleurs que vous racontez
qui est assez incroyable ces concepts
clés moss hérite de ses parents quand
ses parents meurent l'héritage y va à
son mari
et c'est lui qui gère c'est lui qui peut
qu'ils aient pu lui donner ou pas lui
donner oui c'est le chef de famille donc
de toutes façons c'est lui qui tient
langue par exemple c'est une entreprise
en l'occurrence il s'agit d'une grande
entreprise de filature en normandie et
c'est lui qui va bien sûr en tenir les
rênes et qui décide de tout tout point
de vue à l'époque toute façon à femme
n'avait pas de compte en banque
ne vais pas le droit de vote elle
n'avait rien à dire elle était elle
passait de la tutelle au fond son père a
la tutelle de son de son mari dit un
petit peu il ya il ya quand même un
événement qui va changer vous que les
choses c'est cette guerre de 14 puisque
des hommes partent au front et c sont
les femmes et ce qu'il faut tourner la
machine même la machine économique on le
voit dans votre roman avec cette
clémence qui va faire tourner une
entreprise c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être des événements extérieurs qui
ont aussi en dehors de la lutte propre
des femmes provoque est peut-être ce
changement entre entre dans les
relations entre hommes et femmes
mais c'est à dire que vous quand on vole
à la guerre de la guerre de 14
effectivement les comme disaient les
hommes étaient sur le front donc les
entreprises avaient besoin de bras et ce
sont les femmes qui ont occupé les
postes jusqu'à juste là occupée par les
hommes et donc elles ont montré qu'elles
s'en sortent très bien à tous points de
vue bon et effectivement on s'aperçoit
que c'est à ce moment là qu elles ont
quand même pris conscience au fond et
que la société s'est transformée a
commencé à se transformer parce qu'elles
ont pris conscience que finalement elle
était parfaitement légale des hommes et
qu'elles aient les mêmes capacités les
mêmes capacité d'entreprendre les mêmes
capacités pour gérer les choses et que
c'était et bien au delà de l'éducation
des enfants
elle pouvait rentrer vraiment de plain
pied dans la société et c'est à ce
moment là qu'il a été vraiment un
tournant quand même raconté l'issue de
ce premier roman et mes fans c'est vrai
que cette clémence bon elle elle un
courage et une volonté une intelligence
assez exceptionnel vous alors les
vecteurs lyon parce que peut-être
qu'elle va se sortir de ce joug des
hommes et on verra comment
il ya des figures évidemment tutélaire
alors il ya il ya un un personnage dont
vous parlez mais qui est une écrivain
qui a beaucoup compté dans la lutte des
féministes qui s'appelle marie watts
peut-être que les gens ne connaissent
pas trop peut-être que c'est pas mal de
dire et qui elle était
intéressant mais vous dire qu elle étai
parce qu'on reinkin c'est un personnage
moi j'aimais les dents dans le roman des
grandes figures des combats féminins wee
cc bonne de pauvres personnages dans la
moi et c'est une c'est drôle que vous me
disiez ça parce qu'en fait marrer votre
est un personnage que j'ai totalement
créé
et c'est comment quand et là j'ai pris
l'exemple chinois tu
katherine pancol par contre
effectivement là j'ai pris exemple sur
elle on la voit on la voit apparaître
dans le roman elle marie waits est un
personnage parfaitement dormant et s'est
pas laissée passer pour ça que j'ai fait
ça parce que en fait le roman donne une
liberté totale
au sujet coupant par rapport aux sujets
qu'on veut traiter cet
écrivain féministe qui s'appelait marie
mai qui s'est mariée un peintre qui
s'appelait watts est devenue marie watts
non oui oui d'accord mais là mais la
mienne c'est pas mal à l'amour traits
d'un personnage du roman vous avez
absolument oui c'est sa personne et sur
la scène ce qui est parquée padoue dont
je suppose
bien sûr bien sûr j'étais jeune et je
vais faire j'en ai près j'avais pris un
modèle ce qui était intéressant c'était
de montrer aussi les personnels des
grandes figures comme je disais des
combats féminins et crée aussi des
personnages de romans qui les rendent
qui donne beaucoup plus de liberté c'est
beaucoup plus charnel c'est beaucoup
plus concret et ça c'était intéressant
de sauce de ce point de vue là de deux
matchs et un peu les deux
après il faut alors il ya des deux
autres des autres tomes et justement
vous avez parlé de ses personnages et on
s'attache à ces personnages on s'y
attache dans le dans le premier tome est
alors on est très heureux de les
retrouver dans le dans le deuxième et
notamment de retrouver deux héroïnes qui
sont gilberte et et noémie qui sont les
filles clémence
clémence qui dirige une maison de
couture à à paris gilberte qui assume
totalement sa liberté puis un troisième
personnage qui est un peu plus complexe
avec une trajectoire assez intéressante
c'est celui de noémie et nous amy elle
aime passionnément guillaume qui sont
son ami d'enfance et pourtant elle se
laisse marié par son père et elles sont
encore même même schéma que dans le
premier tome et elle se laisse marié un
certain norbert qui s'avère au fur et à
mesure de l'évolution de l'histoire est
bien être un antisémite virulent
donc l'europe s'enfonce dans la guerre
éclair arrivons au pouvoir et pendant
que norbert collabore au régime nazi eh
bien elle noémie elle va entrer en
résistance avec sa soeur qui a la tête
dans un journal clandestin et elle est à
la fois en résistance contre l'occupant
allemand mais aussi en résistance
vis-à-vis de son mari alors on a un
roman plein de rebondissements qui nous
plonge dans les heures sombres de
l'histoire de l'occupation et là encore
et c'est ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
les femmes jouent un rôle très actif
elle dirige des réseaux clandestins elle
prépare des explosifs elle son agent de
liaison et pourtant l'histoire a quand
même minimisé leur action est ce que à
travers donc les personnages de noémie
et gilberte et bien vous avez voulu
rendre justice à toutes ces femmes qui
sont restés dans l'ombre pendant la
résistance bah oui absolument absolument
là j'ai plus directement des grandes
figures de la résistance grandes figures
de femmes de la résistance et que j'ai
mélangé aussi avec mes personnages à moi
mais c'est la leçon
saleh a obtenu le droit de vote au fond
qu'à la fin de la guerre
quand on s'est rendu compte
qu'effectivement elle avait résisté à
l'occupant de toutes les manières il y
en a qui passait dans l'orlando elle
passer des messages
que cacher sous le sous le
bpt choses quelquefois très quotidienne
anodine
pas de transmettre des messages
effectivement sous le panier à
provisions et plein de sobibor il ya
celles qui se battent est effectivement
quasiment physiquement
ça c'était quand même extraordinaire
et quand même une consécration récente
avec la panthéonisation de joséphine
baker
pardon avait avec la panthéonisation de
joséphine baker
il ya quelques semaines et ce avant par
exemple les fines baker oui bien sûr il
y en a eu il y en eut beaucoup d'autres
désistement il a fallu à vraiment
attendre la fin de la guerre quand même
pour s'apercevoir à quel rôle avait joué
quel point c'était important
heureusement le temps qui nous aide
c'est cool trop trop vite il ya le
troisième tome donc il s'appelle un
souffle la dépendance qui nous conduit
de 1960 à 2000 qui est l'époque des
grands combats féministes de la grande
libération de la femme le droit de
disposer de son corps le droit d'avoir
un carnet de chèques aussi enfin le
droit d'avoir son indépendance
économique
est-ce que là on n'a pas trop le temps
malheureusement mais est-ce que vous
pensez que le combat des femmes
est aujourd'hui terminée on voit qui est
un néo féminisme qui arrive qui conteste
au fond de ce fait 10 min sme ancien
est-ce que rhin quatrième tome pour tous
vu des chiffres
disons qu'il est terminée sur un certain
plan son plan
culturel juridique social
dans le cadre dans le cadre du travail
encore quelle encore pas mal de choses à
faire de ce point de vue oui parce que
effectivement les femmes ont une liberté
aujourd'hui qu'elle n'avait pas hier à
tous points de vue que ce soit par
rapport je vais de choisir d'avoir des
enfants ou pas en avoir
mais je pense que de toute façon il
reste dans la société cette société
patriarcale
c'est de faire tomber il reste quand
même des strates
qui seront difficiles à faire partir et
il n'y a que le temps en réalité qui
fait qu'il peut faire faire les choses
peuvent faire avancer les choses pour ça
que je les fais moi surtout le 20e
siècle et il n'y a que le temps qui peu
à peu dans les moeurs des mentalités
changent ça se transforme ça évolue mais
on voit qu'il ya eu des couches et des
couches chape de plomb sur la vie des
femmes pendant des années et ça sera
très difficile de le faire
dans d'éradiquer ça mais je pense on y
arrive on y arrive on est tous doucement
mais on irait merci infiniment alain
leblanc donc ça s'appelle les
conquérantes ces salles on quitte pas un
an commençait voilà on peut pas quitter
ses trois romans logiciels en plus que
c'est chez az
édition est que ces 8 euros chacun
chaque roman donc c'était à la porte et
évidemment de tout le monde merci
infiniment mais très bientôt